a US TV station has been forced to
apologize here's what they did
they they used a picture of seal while
they were reporting on the death of
actor Michael Clarke Duncan yes
that's right they put up this photograph
of seal this we didn't make this up this
really happened and one of our writers
saw this and he wants to comment on the
whole thing so please welcome mr. Deon
Cole
thanks calling America let me start by
saying this I know white people you
think all black people look alike but
let me assure you this that no one looks
like seal you all hear me I mean nobody
still has a unique face I've faced it
nobody has or wants okay mistaken a
black person for seal is like US
mistaken George Clooney for Nick Nolte
all right that hurt didn't it America
but the point that I'm making this [ __ ]
I'd rather look like a real seal been
sealed the only post person on this
earth that can even come close to
resembling sale is Skeletor from he-man
so why people stop paying attention out
there okay thank you very much
[Applause]